sonofa
[Music]
now some folks might say that rising gas
prices are results of political unrest
in the oil-rich Mideast in Africa
increasing global demand for oil and a
failure to develop our own resources but
some would say that Sarah Palin did it
but what if I were to tell you that
America has over a hundred and sixty
three billion barrels and untapped oil
reserves enough to replace our imports
from the Persian Gulf for over 50 years
yet President Obama wants to block
drilling faster than Joe Biden could not
off at one of his bosses speeches but I
thought mr. Obama wants to win the
future
wouldn't winning the future include
reducing our dependence on foreign oil
by some estimates the oil you recently
discovered off the shores of Brazil
could amount to twice the reserves we
have in the United States we want to
work with you we want to help the
technology and support to develop these
oil reserves safely and when you're
ready to start selling we want to be one
of your best customers okay wait so we
shouldn't create jobs and drill here but
we should create jobs in Brazil and then
buy their oil
Zakhar
I knew he hated America so while I'm
paying 80 bucks to fill up my 82 dots
and all mr. Obama can think about is
Brazil which is why I'm endorsing Barack
Obama for president of Brazil I've
already submitted my official
endorsement at Barack for Brazil calm
that's Barack for Brazil dot-com but
don't take my word for it now Barack
Obama running for president here let's
be very upset very upset I miss my
country
this Punk bankrupt the country are gonna
be honest truth friend here okay Barack
I feel bad I feel bad for it coming okay
my heart goes out to him because things
aren't great put them the guy has to
Africa's interests and all these
problems we got going on is he really
interested you have to act like young
people think is he interested maybe he's
not interested yeah brother no Brazil
yeah I guess I can totally see that sure
you can run for president of Brazil the
hello I care the guy wants to taxman of
existence turn around give it to Planned
Parenthood I figure it's not exactly
collecting for the Red Cross I say the
guy wants him Betty I think he'd make a
friggin awesome president Brazil some
people say all right there's some
good-lookin broads down a real
good-looking broad on Copacabana go down
there make some bad decisions we have
you we have Newton the research as I
have done a research president vice
president no matter that smoke
Parliament's would he'd be better off in
Brazil does a goose go barefoot dude
think about it they could be friggin
rocking out with Barack Obama in Brazil
in Brazil with the rock man see how it
works one day your president then back
his presidency is quote it's failure I
am paying an honestly high tax so Barack
Obama can see sad kids and pay for the
health care well whatever gets me more
week
we also tried to get Harrison Ford on
board but um he was just upset about
Obama and Air Force One get off my plane
[Music]
bingo bango bango Baba